I was very much like an amateur mad
little writer like I mostly wrote at
night you all night long go to bed in
the morning or uh um if I was riding
during the day I probably was riding in
a restaurant or a bar you know then
somewhere around in glorious bastards I
um started writing during the day I
started writing say around you know 10:
10:30 11: something like that and then I
write till about uh 5 six or seven and
then I have a pool and I keep it heated
so it's nice then I'd hop in my pool and
just kind of float around in the warm
water and think about everything I've
just written and and maybe I come up
with some neat ideas and then I get out
of the pool and I make notes on those
neat ideas that I came up with like
thinking meditating about it it is
actually is meditating um and then
that's my work tomorrow and that's ended
up becoming this really you know really
enjoyable kind of lovely way to write by
this point in time I'd written enough
scripts and I was definitely a
professional and I just started uh you
know having a a work day